hello and welcome to the shaky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about counts metabolism and the
protein p53 and a new insights into p53
activation by alterations in the ratio
of NADH to NAD+ and as you'll hopefully
understand by the end of the video this
has to do both dimerization of a protein
known as C T V P or C terminal binding
protein so for those who don't follow me
on Twitter baby weight made that p53 is
important protein to me because it's the
protein that I study and I'm I like to
think it's quite a famous protein and
one of the reasons that it is such well
famous and most study protein is because
more than 50% tumors had mutations at
the p53 gene location and these
mutations affects the functional p53
which is as a tumor suppressor and so
p53 is activated by a variety of
different stressors that cells undergo
and activates various different
responses in accordance to these
stresses and this is all to restore
homeostasis within a cell and to prevent
any damage and so for these reasons this
is why p53 is often referred to as a
tumor suppressor well when the protein
gets mutated these responses become
defective and that can lead to cancer
great-auntie malformation so how does it
achieve these different responses well
p53 is a transcription factor so what
that means is it can bind to DNA and
activate the expression of lots of
different genes and the way by which p53
does this is by binding DNA as a
tetramer so p53 is a pretty important
protein and for these reasons its
expression is tightly regulated so in a
normal unstressed out p53 is
continuously made and then degraded and
it's degraded by protein known as mdm2
so this seems like a pretty wasteful
mechanism and the equivalent would be
using all my energy to bake a cake to
then just put that cake
in the bin and to just keep on repeating
this process but then the good thing is
that if suddenly someone wanted a cake
because it's a birthday I would have one
that ready and made to be used straight
away and the same goes for the cell if a
stressful occurrence happens p53 is
already been made that I can just get
activated and stabilized and respond to
this dress and so it's a rapid response
now when I talk about p53 I often like
to show you the slides because they're
pretty much represents how I feel when
it comes to trying to read the
literature surrounding p53 and so
because they're so highly studied
there's so much information out there
but at the same time we still don't
really understand this protein it's a
bit an enigma anyhow I try to do my best
to keep up with the literature and so
I'll seriously read this paper that
talks about p53 and its interaction with
the NADH to NAD+ ratio so before I go
any further into explaining the results
from that paper we just briefly need to
recap what nad Plus actually is so I
follow have spoken about nad plus quite
a few times now but why not is such an
important cofactor for the body and it's
involved in so many different
interactions but its main functions can
be split down into two different areas
one of the witches its role as a redox
coenzyme and the other is as a substrate
for nad Plus consuming enzymes so in
this video we'll focus on its
association as a redox coenzyme and so
this simply refers to its involvement in
metabolic processes so the easiest way I
thought to explain this would be through
a diagram so metabolism involves
breaking down molecules to obtain energy
and so one of these molecules is glucose
and so glucose can get transported into
cells and through a process known as
psychologists can juice ATP and during
this process it also consumes an eighty
plus and produces an eighty plus to NADH
the products of glycolysis can then get
transported into the mitochondria but
they can be further metabolized to
produce more ATP or the energy source
for the cell and also through this
process you can regenerate NAD+
so this makes NAD+ available to be used
again through glycolysis I'm not the way
to regenerate NAD+
is by converting the products of
glycolysis to lactate
but this results in lactate being
secreted from cells and this can have
consequences because it increases the
acidity of the environment so in normal
cells the ratio of NADH to NAD+ is
around 1 to 700
however in cancer cells this ratio can
get increased to around 3 to 700 an
increase in NADH compared to NAD+ can be
seen when there's an increased flux
through glycolysis now there are many
different hallmarks of cancer and one of
these hallmarks is this regulated
metabolism sodium is developed because
of uncontrolled growth and to fuel this
grief the cell needs energy and so this
increased flux and glycolysis is one way
in which it can get more energy and it
can also fade the need to gain through
the mitochondrial pathway which could
generate reactive oxygen species that
could cause damage to the cell this is
often referred to as Arabic glycolysis
because there's so oxygen in the cell so
it could interrogate to the mitochondria
but it instead seems to promote
glycolysis so you have glycolysis in the
presence of sufficient oxygen and so
glycolysis is more than just a linear
pathway and intermediates within this
pathway can be used in different
metabolic pathways as well and one of
these is the pentose phosphate pathway
which can be used to generate NADPH
which is thought to prevent and
alleviate DNA damage in addition
intermediates in the glycolysis pathway
can also be used for nucleotides
biosynthesis and this can aid growth of
the cell the problem is is that
glycolysis uses nad plus and forms NADH
and while she can still regenerate that
nad plus by converting the products to
lactate you don't regenerate as much as
you would do if it went through the
mitochondrial pathway however when the
rates of glycolysis can get too high it
could lead to glycolytic stress which
could actually cause more damage think
the cell and so when I saw the typically
gets damaged there are kind of two
typical responses one of which is cell
death and the other is survival but the
consequences that you could end up with
even more mutations within the DNA which
could further drive tumor development
and so this is where p53 comes in
because as we know it is involved in
responding to cellular stress and indeed
studies have shown that activation of
p53 by preventing so growth reduces that
metabolic demands and other studies have
shown that p53 can promote this pentose
phosphate pathway to produce more NADPH
but what these studies haven't shown is
what actually activates p53 in the first
place in response to this increased
glycolysis flux and so this is what the
paper tried to get at and to some way
it's a lot of really hard work in a very
short period of time what they found was
that this is related to a protein known
as CT BP which stands for C terminal
binding protein and so this protein can
either be found as a monomer or it can
dimerize and previous studies have shown
that it's dimerization is due to the
levels of NADH within a cell so when
there are high levels of NADH it
promotes the dimerization of this
protein and so interestingly when this
protein c gdp is a monomer it is shown
to interact with M DMT which is this
protein that leads to p53 degradation
however when it's in its dimer form it
showed in the study that is p53 got
stabilized and activated so therefore
the ratio of NADH to NAD+ is really
important for activating p53 in this
situation however there are still some
unanswered questions such as how this
interaction between c GBP and mdm2
actually enhances p53 degradation and
how the loss of this interaction can
result in stabilization or p53
and so beyond that there's also some
interesting points to consider from the
study and that firstly is if you have
p53 mutants who don't respond to this
stress response it doesn't prevent their
growth and so as I said cancer cells
with likes of gray this could therefore
be a mechanism by which there's a
selection pressure for mutant p53 that
prevents the inhibition of cell growth
and this is further supported by the
fact that we know Arabic I Colossus is a
hallmark of cancer cells and that p53 is
commonly mutated in cancer the second
interesting point which I feel like I
might get asked if I don't talk about it
is what happens then if people are
taking supplements to increase NAD+
levels well as I said this dimerization
is driven by the ratio of NADH to NAD+
so if you have more nad plus in theory
it would drive the direction such that
CC BP is more often as a monomer this
would therefore prevent p53 activation
and the prevention of cellular growth so
that could be seen as a bad thing but on
the flip sides by having high energy
plus levels it prevents the increase of
the stress response in the first place
because the NADH to NAD+ ratio which
remained low but bottom line I don't
really nearly answer and it would
definitely be more complicated than this
because we know nad plus has multiple
functions beyond just being a redox
coenzyme but I hope this is given a good
insight into cancer metabolism and
potential links between p53 and any deep
last levels so hopefully you've learnt
something and as always thanks listening